this video was made possible by
curiosity a stream when you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash Wendover
you'll also get access to nebula the
streaming video platform that Wendover
is a part of I need not tell you what
happened in March 2020 whether you're
watching this now or far in the future
that date will forever remain in
people's minds as when the century's
first pandemic emerged it will remain in
people's minds as when the era of social
distancing and isolation began it will
remain in people's minds as when they
got sick or when a loved one got sick or
worse in addition though for the
millions of people worldwide working in
the aviation industry March to 2020 will
mark the date when they lost their jobs
and their company started turning the
Sabbath it will mark the beginning of
the end there is perhaps no industry
more severely impacted by kovin 19 than
aviation as it is a brand new virus in
these early days when there is no
immunity or vaccines the only way to
stop or slow its spread is through
physically isolating people that is
intrinsically in opposition to what
Aviation is aviation works to bring
people together that meant that one of
the first measures governments
implemented to slow the spread was to
ban travel when the virus first emerged
is transmission primarily occurred in
China with only isolated cases elsewhere
from those who had traveled from the
epicenter for this issue the solution
was simple ban travel from China a
number of countries notably including
the u.s. barred foreigners who had
recently been in China from entering
their borders and in response to the
sharp decline in demand a number of
Airlines canceled their flights to
greater China the financial implications
of this were limited as few foreign
airlines are significantly exposed to
China partly due to the strength of the
Chinese Airlines most of those mainland
Chinese airlines meanwhile are
government-owned
so they could take the hit of course
nearby Asian airlines like scoot Cathay
Pacific and AAA would struggle but the
lock down of China was more or less a
weather herbal hit
but then the virus spread first to South
Korea
so Airlines canceled flights to South
Korea then to Iran so Airlines canceled
flights to Iran then to Italy so
Airlines canceled flights to Italy but
then it seeped through Italy's porous
borders to take hold of the entirety of
Europe that was the moment when two
Airlines the situation became severe
Europe is home to by revenue three of
the world's six largest airlines the
Lufthansa Group air france-klm and IAG
to have a virus devastating their home
territory was an untenable situation
nobody wants to travel to the center of
pandemic but soon the untenable
situation became worse on Wednesday
March 11th television switched on to the
American president sitting behind his
desk in the Oval Office a speech in this
setting is reserved for only the most
solemn occasions only for such addresses
occurred in the entire 2010s decade the
president laid out some steps in his
administration's response to the virus
the most stunning of which being a
complete ban on all foreign travelers
from Europe that was unprecedented
Europe and the US are two of the most
culturally and economically linked
regions in the world and never before
would anyone even imagine anything even
close to a complete travel ban between
the two the amount of individuals this
would impact was astronomical the North
Atlantic is home to one of the busiest
flows of long-haul flights in the world
more than 1,700 aircraft per day cross
the Atlantic many of those enormous
wide-body Jets these are some of the
most profitable flights for airlines out
there to imagine that this would all
just come to a stop was unthinkable
now Delta American and United would join
the big European three to have their
demand slashed by the virus all six of
the world's largest airlines by revenue
went into crisis mode beyond just the
transatlantic flying entry Europe in US
domestic travel figures dropped off a
cliff as one example United Airlines the
fourth largest airline in the world
issued a press release announcing a 60%
reduction in their flight capacity
April 2020 with those drastic cuts they
predicted an average load factor how
full their planes are of 20 to 30
percent since then they've cut flights
even further most every airline in
Europe started experiencing net negative
bookings that means that they were
refunding more bookings than they had
coming in some airlines including Qantas
Virgin Australia
WestJet and more decided to cancel all
but their domestic flights other
airlines including Lotte Brussels
Airlines and Austrian Airlines decided
to just completely closed down for a few
weeks or months they would fly no
flights at all since its occurrence 9/11
has been the defining crisis for the
aviation industry since civil aviation
began traffic numbers just grew and grew
and grew until suddenly on a sunny
September morning that all stopped it
was bad and airlines did go bankrupt but
overall the industry eventually made it
out the other end
less than a week after coronavirus
became a pandemic though one thing
became abundantly clear two airlines
coronavirus to them financially was
worse than 9/11 this was the most severe
drop-off in passenger demand in the
history of aviation airlines are no
strangers to doing things that lose
money there is perhaps no industry out
there that so robustly embraces the idea
of a lost leader than aviation airlines
will go to great lengths to retain
loyalty both of individual travelers and
of their corporate contracts for example
airlines can and often do keep routes
flying in the depths of winter when
traffic is the lowest in order to
reliably present themselves as a go-to
airline for their customers if say
there's a us-based company with
significant amounts of travel to
Barcelona they're only going to set up a
corporate contract with an airline that
can fly their employees there year-round
therefore American Airlines for example
might fly there for 12 months a year
even if only eight of those turn a
profit that's because with the loss of
corporate contracts they might only turn
a profit flying to Barcelona five months
a year so overall yearly profit
be higher by taking a loss for months a
year the equation changes when nobody
including those corporate customers want
to travel though therefore with AK
rotavirus reaching pandemic level in one
of the lowest traffic periods of the
year
airlines quickly were able to make the
decision to cut loss leading long-haul
flights these cuts are deep the
Lufthansa Group for example the seventh
largest airline in the world my
passengers is reducing its long-haul
schedule to a Seoul flight from Zurich
to Newark then flights from Frankfurt to
Sao Paulo
Newark Chicago Montreal Tokyo Bangkok
and Johannesburg to think that this is
what the seventh largest airline in the
world in 2020 looks like is unimaginable
but the situation at the world's largest
airline American Airlines is even more
severe this is the very long haul
Network during the corona virus they'll
fly just Miami to London Dallas to
London and Dallas to Tokyo this is a
situation without a lot of good news
jobs will be lost and airlines will go
bankrupt but there is plenty of hope
that the industry can survive while this
fall will be far airlines do have
further to fall than after 9/11 in 1999
United American and Delta achieved
operating margins the ratio of their
earnings to revenues of six point eight
six point five and twelve point seven
percent respectively in 2019 those
margins were nine point nine six point
six and fourteen point O percent these
are small differences but a few
percentage points can mean the
difference between life and death for an
airline another saving grace for
airlines is the recent plummet in oil
prices this is the byproduct of a price
war going on between two of the world's
largest oil producers Saudi Arabia and
Russia the two countries have long
worked together to limit output based on
demand and therefore more or less
control oil prices but after Russia
refused to reduce their output Saudi
Arabia responded by slashing prices and
increasing production in order to price
Russia out of the market therefore the
same barrel of jet fuel that would have
cost Airlines $60 in February costs only
$40
in March 20 20 that's a significant
discount on Airlines biggest cost and if
we were not for the biggest drop in
demand in the history of aviation they
would be celebrating a huge increase in
profits in the midst of the crisis
though they're taking the small win of
smaller losses the aviation industry as
a whole
never truly recovered from the effects
of 9/11
that's because recovery implies getting
back to normal and that's something that
never happened after 9/11 and certainly
it will never happen after coronavirus
it's nearly impossible to predict what
will happen in the aftermath of a
situation never seen before as we've
seen already and we'll continue to see
the response to extraordinary
circumstances is extraordinary measures
there for the industry will emerge from
the other end something completely new
and novel how deep the dip sinks will be
determined by how high the curve soars
and that will be determined by world
governments organizations and more than
all how every individual out there
responds to covin 19 for those of you
subscribed to nebula a brand new
original called money made by the
fantastic youtuber Tom Scott just
released I along with Sophie Ward my
Boyd Nia Mulder and Rowan Francis were
subjected to five of Tom's games in
order to win real money this was an
enormous amount of fun to participate in
and it's just as fun to watch which you
can do exclusively on nebula the best
way to get access to nebula of course is
by subscribing to curiosity stream to
thousands of fantastic documentaries and
nonfiction shows that's because
curiosity's room offers a bundle deal
with nebula so that you get access to
both trimming sites for just twenty
dollars a year at curiosity stream comm
slash Wendover that's truly the best
deal in streaming especially concerning
that on nebula in addition to my Tom
Scott's and everyone else's originals
you can watch all Wendover and half as
interesting videos completely ad-free
once again that bundle deal is available
at curiosity stream column slash
Wendover and by signing up you'll be
supporting Wendover productions and
plenty of other independent educational
creator
you